[Music]
I
you know those tedious nine-to-five
office job sentimental boring yeah yeah
what hell is that
when is timís na become Buddhist
greeting humble mortal
welcome to inner peace pretty what the
hell is going on yeah what's with the
getup and why does she Ted shape it
meaning her hair before normally a line
like that would point me to trash you
but I have achieved enlightenment really
and how did you I have seen the ultimate
bad roofie after 10 years of seeing crap
I have finally come across a film so
terrible it is lifted me to a higher
plane I can bring about peace where
there is none and even predict
Transformers movies without having to
see them ok critic will bite which movie
gave you different alignments Rob
Schneider is countering in the studio
that brought you all the Barbie movie
sounds doubly right
no I'm of the north yeah
[Music]
that's right after 10 years of doing
this I'm finally giving in and reviewing
the film I've gotten countless requests
to review some exceptions that like two
movies I reviewed I have some sort of
nostalgic connection whether it come out
years ago or was based on this couch
property this however has no nostalgia
connections no nostalgia characters it's
not even a medal but I'm gonna review it
in honor of you guys watching for 10
incredible years so let's get ready to
watch a film so terrible it can bring
you into a whole new realm of reality
hey aren't you guys gonna get ready for
the sketches Oh we'd like to but oh man
those clips you showed us really brought
us to enlightenment already yeah me too
we're not just taking it easy because we
worked our asses off in the Wonder Woman
review I understand being a piece in
your new in lightnings we do it better
if you stop yapping oh sorry we don't by
popular demand this is norm of the north
that's all opens with music that's
trying whoa hey too hard for a Rob
Schneider project
[Music]
this literally has farting lemmings
composure you do not want to waste your
a material on this we see our main
character norm played by human shrug rob
schneider
any mumbles to himself arguably what's
the real Rob Schneider mumbles to
himself every morning don't listen to
the haters norm you got this reading the
week boys
caribou yeah okay let's play a game I'm
sure you're already playing it at home
let's run away first rap character from
another with you with this okay let's
see norm is obviously the lion from
Madagascar who doesn't fit in I know we
wouldn't kill the seat up we got the
brother bear moose both of them actually
oh I'm dying testicle I'm you know the
annoying testicles are everywhere
there's the Simpson ones and Despicable
Me the ginger crap lungs from brave the
petting zoo of the noise from Lorax the
black and white and overused all over
from Madagascar penguins
the wily coyote one from my page in fact
let's go their backgrounds too while
we're at it as well as their inability
to bring joy and now you're the
terrifying combination of all but with
these Bigfoot testicles known as the
lemmings who sadly do not jump off a
cliff in this movie I'm sure you'll be
authentic on that detail now let's not
forget the generic female support who's
so essential to this movie she literally
only has one word in a scene
hi and we hit action mark that means
were real movie now let's celebrate with
a shitty transition not like a real
movie
you want to know why I'm not going to
eat you you got a minute well maybe an
hour or a better writer do you have a
better writer cuz this so isn't flowing
Silla norm reveals that he can talk with
human and he's the only polar bear who
can apparently do it can't you see were
wild animals here did you just talk to
me how does he have this medical power
let me and certainly no other bear had
these weird feelings that I had so he
sees the king of the Arctic who also
happens to be his grandpa
I too could speak to our human visitors
polar bears are icons of the Arctic norm
and an icon with a voice can be very
powerful and being yeah that's our
shitty way of saying we just can but
these are powerful icons are used for
lame movies and annoying air campaign
what would you do for a Klondike bar
would you watch normal ignore not a
chance
oh he also discovers he likes dancing
because they want to see if they can
turn this into this Christ everything in
this movie is a ripoff even this scene
looks like a coke commercial buts the
crappy second-rate version so would
probably be this I just realize you know
how there's always a bad Asylum knockoff
film every single time an anime flick
comes out like every animated flick
Norma the North doesn't have one
that's how bad it is it meant all on
asylum knock off this is if we're told
in the apocalypse he is a brother named
Stan played by Gabriel Iglesias he's in
this scene and so let me give you some
advice bro act with your stomach and not
your heart now if you'll excuse me I
just keep this movie to my talents are
wasted in hire material including nut
job to Annoying Orange and holy shit how
the hell did I get that he likes to put
on a show for the tourists including
lemmings in tuxes seals and ice cannon
and twerking whales
[Music]
you know this movie is only ten minutes
in and it's already created two new
Commandments no twerking wails and no
saying you're not going to do something
followed by a scene of you immediately
doing it the arctic shake was for your
bachelor party I'd never do that for the
human tourists never never never
Wow that transition was so lazy and
uninspired you could just replace it
with this
I've never do that for the human
tourists never never never
in fact for this movie I think there
should be a new commandment that just
says no nothing else just no hey an idea
for no I thought be funny if maybe no
but what it'd be cool perhaps is the
sculpted an entire tablet simply for
this commandment the answer is no but
perhaps if I could just God has a
sharpshooter pointing at you all the
time don't give him a reason something
else you'll notice is that the camera is
always spinning in this movie it's like
the camera operator is in constant orbit
around whatever piece of shit is being
photographed I feel like I'm on a
dizzying right whoa the arctic shakes Oh
what spinning too much for you I just
had to listen to the dialogue to get it
there is nothing we can do nightmare not
scary at all
people on John Broadway
no no that's not what I wanted to be I
thought you didn't want to be a scary
animal you know you can get along and be
people with people intruders they've
never done anything for us except come
to our land uninvited motivation you
drunk again only when you're dope right
in fact he said Oh spontaneously hates
humans that he's looking to get rid of a
person's house that suddenly pops up
there's a human house right here on
grandpa's land you want to be king a
future king isn't supposed to get so
emotional Shannon no more talking human
yes don't use the gift your Grandpa's in
was good to talk to humans that you
don't want to talk to because you hate
them now anyway
just know that what you and I have is a
great gift
oh and by the way you know these three
lemmings are following norm around like
they're close friends yeah
this is the first time we're seeing that
to go to see the house in the scene
prior but aside from that we've never
seen them before or maybe we have this
just want to be painted tribbles but
following him out with their heads hung
low because they have such a connection
with him the first time they're even
acknowledging that they're in any way
friends
I mean finishing this draw relationship
out of nowhere chef lazy isn't it bill
[Music]
three come alone
well they turned me oh that's right bill
picking the temporary king of Iceland
mm-hmm well good to have you back bill
mm-hmm
[Music]
but hey maybe not money but that
mistakes I mean they didn't evolve this
gear there from one word to a 20-second
scene yeah I counted 20 seconds but
don't just stand for the human fight for
our home instead okay I won't let you
down I will uphold a check that you got
for one minute of dialogue it's the
least I can do for the leaf that we gave
you we have to do something I have to do
something
ah number one or number two you know I'm
just going to start a conspiracy cipher
how this don't get made theory one they
took the Adam Sandler joke so bad even
he won't use him in his movie saw the
flip book he made of a polar bear
instead of trying to write on your line
and lions gave me to film outfit before
Netflix could get the right I can't
prove that I'm right but you can't prove
that I'm wrong they see the human house
is there for a real estate commercial
which norm plans to sabotage because
again he sees the value in human life a
director always delivers and never quits
miracles the footage we never see that
cameraman again so I'm just gonna
presume he's dead
bringing the chill counter surprisingly
to how I questioned your all age
appropriate rating Dell foundation by
the way I didn't Photoshop that that's
totally on Barris we come back it's just
feel you generalist you must think all
animals look the same yes I was shocked
by that line - Rob Schneider and racial
sensitivity usually go to a hand at hand
an agent for Greene homes named biro
played by Heather Graham talked with her
daughter Olympia when she notices norm
in the distance why did you talk to me
when confronted with a polar bear and is
it mirrors the animation so awkward that
when this kid turns sideways her eye
looks like the devil Venus flytrap yeah
I will swallow your soul Lennie
mommy had an idea véra films norm
chasing her and sent it to her boss mr.
green played by Kim Jung and I'm not
gonna lie this line of reasoning is so
strange that like violent vomit I have
to bring it up in chunks I got some
really great footage of a polar bear
that almost attacked me I love it I love
it this bear is a star this will
definitely get me approval for the Polar
Council why would a dangerous animal
sell home pregnant Lee nobody wants
property with a bear living on it unless
Nicholas Cage is hiding inside and don't
tempt him would that offer you need from
us we need a real symbol of the Arctic
who can convince these morons to buy my
homes find an actor who looks just like
that bear well get problem solving Meets
The Mummy but second why would you need
an actor who looks like a bear is that
some sort of trick they don't teach you
a real estate school well I was going to
turn you down but dude looks like a bear
you can connect the dots let's use the
Arctic to sell the Arctic booyah
why did she gasped I mean yes any movie
that says booyah should be given ball so
they can be castrated but should she be
happy she fixed her problem maybe it
suddenly hit her that her daughter has
demo line seriously what was that
finally why is Kenji on doing his worst
patton oswalt bring the commercial and
the model back home to New York and I'll
see you tomorrow
manana did they approach patton oswalt
on the first thing he said was do you
know who I not ken Jeong and then are
like oh we can you can junk his career
is on the right let's see if we can put
us back to that by casting him as
someone who's supposed to move funny but
instead moves like a sped up inflatable
outside of a car rental you know can
this movie be like split where it's all
secretly connected to another movie
because I would kill if this was
actually the prequel to Alaska
ignore the North gets the treatment the
mother got in that this would at least
be into double digits some norm sneaks
onto a submarine aloft it's dentures and
Vera comes home to her daughter who is
presumably Sherman after he got a sex
change which let's be honest we all saw
their coming it is only a tour we still
needed to reach help and mom you're
putting too much pressure on yourself
okay I know it's a cartoon I shouldn't
be questioning this but how is that neck
supporting that head like a straw trying
to balance the potato I'm just gonna
question those logistics like the entire
film norm comes across two henchmen who
try to catch him but he runs outside and
he finds her oh sorry about that where
was it
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry I sneezed apparently that was
enough to totally lose track of what was
going on
I can't let me rewind this here okay
they confuse the guy in a bear suit for
on them rather than call the cops he
practices ninjutsu on them okay now
everything makes sense sorry I must have
seemed really stupid before I explained
it a green finds out from the terrifying
dream you had about Gilbert Gottfried
and drag that he doesn't give his
approval ratings up he can't sell houses
in the Arctic but not before an
essential scene of the lemmings pissing
in a fish tank all ages with oh it's
rated PG all ages and by the way they
clearly have their time priorities
planned out we had under a minute
showing Norns connection to his love
interest literally no time dedicated to
showing Norns connection to a comic
relief but lemmings pissing 30 seconds
and trust me it gets uncomfortable
they're all just staring at
it has life now
[Applause]
thank you all for coming oh what's wrong
with you
the loving prison go back to that that
needs to be all right I suppose people
came for something other than rat urine
did they norm is immediately hired as
the spokesperson don't have to Greene a
surprise and image as scary as a killer
bear is that scary as a killer bear
again poses campaigns before and he even
brought Arctic lemmings oh yes they
realize the arrows are waves and they
went right back to the lemming pissing
so don't be afraid to stare the movie
says it's okay
hello everything well he's too authentic
I mean we need a bear that is happy that
makes people feel warned and safe like
that scary video you sent earlier how'd
you movie movie but he dances with winds
him over lady discovers he really is a
bear which makes him angry again so he
goes into a restaurant with a gun to try
and kill him because yeah this will get
your approval ratings watch the local
news caught your outburst everyone's
talking about norms and look at our
approval ranking look okay I know this
is a kid film
presumably one usual when punishing your
kids but I'm sorry how can any of this
result in higher approval ratings that's
like a celebrity being found guilty of a
crime going to jail when she's released
and how she's worth even more money if
you thought that joke was too easy screw
you at Dharma the North they can go for
the easy one why can't i okay so they
want to use a norm again making this
pointless detour
what 26 the mom still tries to hold out
for more well normally he has to look
for a new job and a place to live not
all of us can afford a fancy green condo
which I hear is fully furnished and
uninhabited this is better than
Schneider's usual bargaining languages
do you know who I know so they end up
also giving him a nice place to live and
in this film's natural progression we
move from pissing lemmings - farting
lemmings but they are merciful on this
one only 10 seconds are dedicated to
this ok ok look
[Music]
I'd like to point out by the way that
when I typed farting lemmings
autocorrect asked if I was sure this was
my life sadly yes oh don't cry here was
going to put him on a talk show but
before she does she introduces into her
daughter Olivia yeah hi mr. Chris I'm
sorry I didn't your mom is very good at
her job
Olivia sometimes I wish she wasn't so
good at her job if it meant she got to
spend more time with me you know I make
fun of this movie but in all honesty it
is very impressive to see the first
fully computer animated motion picture
oh I don't mean animate with computers
how I mean animated by computers because
only a machine would combine all of
these cliches and think it's somehow
equal cinematic emotion and I actually
have that computer right here the
telomere plays our ninth out say hello
9000 hello 9000 oh that sounds like you
er it's years old and not very funny but
nevertheless you picked up on it and
that's very impressive of course it is
how I make what you humans have called
give up films I've now tell me 9,000 how
did you come up with these ideas I do
not come up with anything I calculate
what is used in every movie and put it
in my movie where most films choose to
focus on only one or two of these
cliches to make an emotional connection
I say suck it and replace the emotion
with more cliches the misunderstood hero
the busy parent the budding friendship
dance sequences corporate villains fart
jokes pee jokes the list is never ending
is what you do with normal annoys no for
Rob Schneider movies I use a different
formula oh yeah and what's that
Rob Schneider derp dee derp derp dee
derp dee derp dee derp until one day the
durpa durpa durpa durpa hider is dead
derp dee derp da teetley derp dee derp
dee dum rated pg-13 also foundation upon
Oh
I mean PG that's right parental guidance
suggested even though it's been approved
for all ages
after going on TV where they show the
security footage with such incredible
angles and editing you'd swear they were
just too lazy to animate another scene
norm in the middle of the interview
dances yes he wasn't asked they weren't
talking about it he just kind of
randomly starts doing it it just comes
right the hell I'm nowhere and suddenly
we're in a musical and like if in the
middle of this review I suddenly started
dancing mr. green takes norms voice and
makes it sound like he supports putting
his houses in the Arctic so he goes to
Vera's because he remembers hearing that
Olympia was a genius I actually think
Olympian myself are a lot of like two
peas in a pod I see yes that's exactly
right you had one scene and now you're
immediately besties I think this whole
entire film was some idiot looking
through the garbage finding the shredded
first drafts of successful films taping
them back together tidying it up on a
computer setting the computer on fire
inhaling the fumes death and this was
the mocking eulogies an asshole gave at
his funeral and that is the best-case
scenario obvious says he should go after
the investor then of course he happens
to know exactly where they are and norm
shows them Greene already signed off on
the homes without giving their approval
how did you get these that's a very
small Harry Associates or leave mr.
Greene of this flash drive every joke
that comes from those Puetz of misery
should be followed by that kid crying
from a Christmas story
but things get crazier when norm finds
out Green has his grandfather and
apparently has been holding him this
whole time what the hell's the play in a
bet you could have cut the grandfather
out of the second half of the film and
you wouldn't miss a damn thing what did
he have more of a story and then the
director just sent a note saying who
gives or should because if that's the
case how do you explain us I see where
they escape get captured again only to
escape again yes the scenes only last a
few minutes there's even a fake out to
make you think that Norman is
grandfather died only to find out
they're really still alive literally
follow later my another fake out making
a thing then Norman as grandfather died
only to find out that they're actually
still alive oh my god
this dumb son comes to repeat he just
keeps going over and over and over and
on the continual loop it's like
Groundhog Day except instead watching
some where we're watching Rob Schneider
instead of watching Bill Murray we're
watching Rob Schneider
[Music]
so the villains plan is thwarted vera
and Olympia live happily as pencil necks
with next literally pencils and the Rob
Schneider bear procreate and we never
think of that concept again
[Music]
[Applause]
and that was normal but north film so
bad that it helped me achieve
enlightenment voids bursting Garbage
Pail Kids
well no nothing's worse than Garbage
it's worse than Mamma Mia okay nothing's
as bad as that either by a service guys
no the man not right in the head not
exactly Oh Joe
you're ruining my Zen thing they
enforced it okay it's not bad as any of
those it's just your run-of-the-mill bad
don't get me wrong this is a tough film
to get through it's stupid it's lazy is
annoying but it's nothing you wouldn't
expect it doesn't surpass the unlike
ability I would imagine I'd get from an
animated Rob Schneider play if anything
it gives the exact crap I thought I
would get so yeah it sucks but I can't
say it's the worst thing ever or even in
my top ten of worst things ever it's
just bad but that means then I didn't
achieve enlightenment I just watched a
really stupid flick another be smarter
I'm not any Dumber okay I'm a little
dumber but this isn't the worst impact a
film is had on me I can't see without
seeing I can't bring about peace whether
it's in peace oh my god I shave my head
I look like the joke is now complete and
total jackass for what Norma the friggin
north I cannot my hair for this I'm down
what have I done with myself wait you
still think you had hair
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
thurb
hello Doug Walker here wasn't messing
around it really did and we are doing
the charity shout out here as usual and
this week we are doing Project Hope
Project hope delivers essential medicine
and supplies volunteers and medical
training to prevent disease promote
wellness respond to disaster and save
lives around the globe Project Hope has
been a leader in providing community
education and healthcare worker training
that helps hold the global epidemic of
diseases such as diabetes obesity and
cardiovascular disease they also utilize
Health Affairs which is the leading
journal of health policy thought and
research exploring health policy issues
of current concerns and domestic and
international spheres they've also
gained a reputation of financial
integrity and efficiency with more than
90 percent of their expanded resources
supporting their life-saving health
projects around the world if you look at
their site and their YouTube page you
can see the hard-working volunteers in
various places and people they help on a
daily basis it's a wonderful
organization that needs your support
take a click and see how you two can
help them out
[Music]
you